[Applaudissements]
aux médias non pardon on s'est connus en
colonie c'est une preuve non 6 et 12
passes et non
[Applaudissements]
machaie dans le préquel du sla de sendai
il avait un carré car si tôt pour
annoncer aux téléspectateurs de moundir
à l'état
[Applaudissements]
pour tuer ce dossier aux téléspectateurs
vous étiez cyril thomas étrange pour moi
de vous voyez mon animateurs en colonies
non un mouvement dans un mouvement de
jeunesse je te dire le nom du mouvement
de jeunesse d'esch s'appelait tout
simplement
shalom loisirs j'ai pas trouvé qu'il
avait un espèce de taré qui me
ressemblait à une voiture vous le dis on
regarde et je peux vous dire là vous
allez me ressortir souvent ça sur hbo
boucle sur twitter pourrait réagir à
cette photo qui désire vous pouvez me
charrier à côté baba sy voilà c est
décédé à mieux s'accepter
c'était le grand viande de lapin
[Applaudissements]